From WBEZ Chicago, It's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《这美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。
[TRAIN SOUNDS]
[火车声]
There's this bridge that's part of Chicago's Lake Shore Drive that crosses the Chicago River. You can see this bridge from the offices of WBEZ. It's really close. But unless you're really looking for it, you would miss the hole that is halfway across the bridge. It's at the foot of some steel girders, in between lanes of traffic, just 12 inches by 36.
在芝加哥湖岸大道上，有一座横跨芝加哥河的桥梁。从WBEZ的办公室就能看到这座桥，离得很近。但除非你特意去寻找，否则你绝不会注意到桥中央有一个洞。它位于钢梁脚下，在车道之间，只有12英寸乘36英寸大。
I'd cross the two lanes and then I'd go to where the hole is, and when there was no cars coming at the time I'd slip in.
我会穿过两条车道，走到那个洞所在的地方，当确认没有车过来时，我就会溜进去。
Richard Dorsay became momentarily famous in Chicago, in December 2004, when police learned from one of Richard's friends that Richard and this friend had been living down there, inside the frame of the bridge, tucked way in the rafters underneath the roadway, for years. Authorities kicked him out from this space that Richard says was probably 14- or 18-feet long, and about as wide as two lanes of traffic, with the steel frame of the bridge for walls and a concrete floor. The ceiling was the roadway. Where, out of wood that Richard and his friend mostly took from a construction site, they built three rooms in the dank space, a supply room and two bedrooms. There was electricity from a long extension cord that they hid with piping, and plugged into a regular electric socket in the bridge down below.
理查德·多赛在2004年12月曾短暂地成了芝加哥的名人，当时警方从理查德的一位朋友那里得知，理查德和这位朋友多年来一直住在那儿，就在桥的框架内，缩在路面下方的椽子里。当局将他从这个理查德所说的约14到18英尺长、约两条车道宽的空间里赶了出来，那里有钢制桥梁框架作为墙壁，地面是混凝土的。天花板就是桥面。理查德和他的朋友主要从建筑工地捡来木材，在这个阴暗的空间里盖了三个房间：一个储藏室和两个卧室。那里有电，电是从一根长长的延长线引来的，他们用管道遮掩住电线，并插在下方桥梁的普通插座上。
They made a big stink out of this when actually it hit the papers. I had like a 20inch TV, which was a pain in the butt to get in, but I did it. And I had a little heater and various other things, like a PlayStation, video games, videotapes, VHS. And I'd come back towards the evening and sit back and play the PlayStation and, you know, maybe have some beer, drink some beer and see how far I can go in a driving game before I end up crashing.
当这事儿上报纸的时候，他们把它闹得沸沸扬扬的。我有一台20英寸的电视机，搬进去费了老鼻子劲了，但我还是做到了。我还带了个小取暖器和其他杂七杂八的东西，比如PlayStation游戏机、电子游戏、录像带、VHS磁带。我会在傍晚回来，坐下来玩玩游戏，你知道，也许喝点啤酒，看我在赛车游戏里能跑多远才会撞车。
But this wasn't just an adult treehouse, hidden away inside an old bridge. It was an adult treehouse inside in old drawbridge, a working drawbridge over the Chicago River, that every now and then would raise, turning the entire three-room apartment on its side, pulling the extension cord out of the outlet.
但这不仅仅是一个躲在旧桥里的成人树屋。它是一个躲在旧开合桥里的成人树屋，一座横跨芝加哥河的正在运行的开合桥，每隔一段时间就会升起，把整个三室公寓侧翻过来，顺便把延长线从插座里拔出来。
The only thing that was actually a little on the scary side was the first time the bridge went up. Everything would tilt, literally. It'd be like a one-sided earthquake. And instead of it shaking, it'd be like the ground just lifting up and tilting.
唯一真正让人有点害怕的是第一次桥升起来的时候。一切都在倾斜，真的。就像一场单侧的地震。它不是在晃动，而是地面直接升起并倾斜。
And then, when that bridge is vertical, that bridge really is like vertical.
而且，当桥垂直立起时，它看起来真的很垂直。
You're standing straight up when in a laying-down position.
你明明是躺着的姿势，却变成了站得笔直。
Some of his stuff was bungee-corded down. The heavy stuff, like the TV, he kept against the back wall of his room, the wall that tilted to become the floor.
他的一些东西是用蹦极绳固定住的。重的东西，比如电视机，他放在房间的后墙上，那是倾斜后会变成地面的那堵墙。
And sometimes I'd move things just before the bridge went up, because you can hear the motors unlock.
有时我会赶在桥升起前挪动东西，因为你能听到电机解锁的声音。
And there's a bell on that bridge?
桥上还有个铃铛吗？
Yeah, there's bells.
是的，有铃铛。
So the bells go off, you hear the motors start.
所以铃铛响了，你就能听到电机启动的声音。
I'd just sit back and ride it. And I'd just lay there, and then as the bridge went up, I slowly slid towards the wall, and then, when it was totally standing straight up, then I'd be standing straight up on that back wall
我就坐着随它去。我躺在那里，随着桥升起，我慢慢滑向墙壁，然后，当它完全垂直站立时，我就站在了那堵后墙上。
With the mattress next to you?
床垫就在你旁边？
Yes. And after that first time it was kind of like a rush going down a hill on a roller coaster. You know, where you get that laugh and you feel all relieved and it's real great, you know?
是的。那第一次之后，那种感觉就像坐过山车下坡一样。你知道，你会那种大笑，感到如释重负，感觉真的很棒，对吧？
Richard's been out of there since 2004. He lives with friends in a house now, in the suburbs. And when he talks about his little nest in the bridge today, he is surprisingly unsentimental. It was hot as hell in the summer, he says, and freezing in the winter. And the ceiling was just low enough, five feet and change, that he used to hit his head. But as we talked about it, there was also this.
理查德从2004年起就离开了那里。他现在和朋友住在郊区的一所房子里。今天当他谈起他在桥上的那个小窝时，出人意料地毫无温情。他说夏天热得要命，冬天冷得要死。天花板低得要命，只有五英尺多一点，他以前老撞到头。但当我们谈起它时，还有这一点。
Richard, if your friend hadn't turned you into the cops--
理查德，如果你朋友没把你举报给警察——
Would I still be there, is that the question?
你是问我会不会还待在那儿，对吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Probably. Probably. To me, it's a world of safety and comfort, where to someone else, they see it, oh, another drawbridge, whoopadeedo.
可能会。可能会。对我来说，那是一个安全舒适的世界，而别人看到它，哦，又是一座开合桥，有什么大不了的。
The bridge connects point A to B, but there can be a whole life on a bridge. And today, on the radio show, we stop there and stay for an hour and see what happens there. We have three stories of people at three bridges on three continents. Act one is in China. Act two is in the border of Egypt. Act three in Florida. Stay with us.
桥连接着A点和B点，但桥上也可以有完整的人生。今天，在广播节目中，我们要在那里停留一个小时，看看会发生什么。我们有三个故事，关于三个大陆上三座桥上的人们。第一幕在中国。第二幕在埃及边境。第三幕在佛罗里达。请继续收听。
Act one, Troubled Bridge Over Water.
第一幕：水上的忧愁之桥。
In 2003, a year before Richard Dorsay got kicked out of the bridge at the Chicago River, halfway around the world, in Naan-jing, China, a man named Chen Sah, Mr. Chen, took up residence in a bridge, or anyway he spent his weekends there, 10 hours a day away from his wife and daughter. The bridge he chose is this concrete communist monstrosity, four miles long, covered with slogans that celebrate the worker, four lanes of traffic and thousands of pedestrians on the top deck, two train tracks on the lower over the Yangtze River into Naan-jing, a city of seven million.
2003年，也就是理查德·多赛被赶出芝加哥河那座桥的一年前，在地球另一端的中国南京，一个叫陈思的男人，也就是陈先生，住进了一座大桥里，或者说他每周末都待在那儿，每天花10个小时远离他的妻子和女儿。他选择的那座桥是一个巨大的混凝土共产主义怪物，长四英里，上面覆盖着赞美劳动者的口号，顶部有四条机动车道和成千上万的行人，长江下层有两条铁轨，通往拥有七百万人口的城市南京。
Estimates are fuzzy, but the best guess is that one person per week commits suicide off this bridge. Mr. Chen decided he wanted to try to keep them from jumping, and he started to, single-handedly at first, then with an occasional volunteer. The blog that he keeps about this is the most sober, taciturn, non-boastful account of saving lives imaginable. Occasionally, Mr. Chen will insert his feelings. "Beware heavy thoughts," he declares to himself during one entry. "How I wished he would soon be free of this shadow," he says about an old man he saved in another.
估算数据很模糊，但最好的猜测是每周有一人从这座桥上跳下自杀。陈先生决定他要试图阻止他们跳桥，他开始独自行动，后来偶尔会有志愿者加入。他写的关于这件事的博客是你能想象到的关于拯救生命的最清醒、严谨、毫不吹嘘的记录。偶尔，陈先生会流露自己的感受。“谨防沉重的思绪，”他在其中一篇博文中这样提醒自己。“多么希望他能早日从这阴影中解脱出来，”他在谈到救下的一位老人时写道。
But mostly just the facts. Here's a translation from the Chinese: "On July, 25, at 10:30 in the morning, I discovered a woman lying on the bridge railing, on her belly, weeping. I went to her. She wiped her eyes. She said she was just playing and walked toward the center of the bridge. I went with her, and she, very ordinarily, without her cell phone. When I returned at 1:10, I discovered that she had already climbed up on the bridge railing. I restrained her and forced her onto a moped. She is from Naan-jing's Jianye District. Her last name is Jiau, and today she's 45 years old. Because her husband, surname Lee, and 51 years old, is violent towards her and mistreats her, she thought killing yourself would be better. However, she is silent when she thinks of her 15-year-old son."
但大部分只是事实。这是从中文翻译过来的：“7月25日上午10点半，我发现一名女子趴在桥栏杆上哭泣。我走近她。她擦了擦眼睛。她说她只是在玩，然后往桥中央走去。我陪着她，她确实没有手机。当我1点10分回来时，发现她已经爬上了桥栏杆。我制止了她，并强行把她送上了助力车。她来自南京建邺区。她姓焦，今年45岁。因为她丈夫姓李，51岁，对她很暴力，虐待她，她觉得自杀会更好。然而，当想到她15岁的儿子时，她沉默了。”
I thought maybe I'll see him in action. Maybe I'll get to see him save somebody. Just as back story, I mean, I actually came-- I had come from Cambodia, so I was covering these genocide trials, so I wasn't, you know, I didn't have the most optimistic feelings about humanity. And I thought I was going to find something there, like there some--
我本想看看他实地行动。也许能看到他救下某个人。作为背景，我是从柬埔寨过来的，当时在报道种族灭绝审判，所以我当时对人性并没有最乐观的看法。我想我会在那里找到某种东西，像是——
You said you thought you'd find a hopeful figure.
你说你以为会找到一个充满希望的人物。
Yeah. I mean, hope, perseverance, generosity. But as soon as I got on the bridge, I realized that all those notions were completely absurd. I mean, I got instantly depressed. First of all, there's this four-mile long bridge and this one man out there sort of trying to pick out who was going to jump. It just seemed, from a distance, like insurmountable odds to actually maybe pull somebody off the bridge.
是的。我是说希望、毅力、慷慨。但当我一上桥，就意识到所有这些想法都完全荒谬。我的意思是，我立刻就陷入了抑郁。首先，这是一座四英里长的大桥，只有这一个人试图找出谁会跳桥。从远处看，要在桥上救下某个人简直是不可逾越的困难。
Yeah, you wrote in the article, at one point, you said, first of all, there's the cars, then there's the trains and the bridge is shaking, and then there's just like a sea of people, thousands of people, in the rain with umbrellas, going back and forth on the bridge, and he's just one guy kind of walking up and down.
是的，你在文章中写道，有一次你说，首先有汽车，然后有火车，桥在震动，然后还有一片人海，数千人在雨中打着伞，在桥上来来往往，而他只是一个人在桥上走来走去。
And he has this little moped and does a little cruise on the bridge every once in a while, but even that is a somewhat comical sight to behold. You know, he's on this little broken-down moped, put-putting through the crowd with his big pair of binoculars around his neck. You know, I sort of thought, maybe this isn't even real, like maybe this blog is a complete figment of his imagination, or a fiction that he constructs once a week, and I just don't see how this guy can save anybody out here.
他有一辆小助力车，偶尔在桥上巡视一圈，但即便如此也是一个相当滑稽的场景。你知道，他骑着那辆破旧的助力车，脖子上挂着一副大望远镜，在人群中突突地穿行。我甚至想过，这也许根本不是真的，也许这个博客完全是他想象出来的产物，或者他每周编造出来的虚构故事，我不明白这个家伙怎么能在这种地方救下任何人。
And you write in your article, he won't really to talk to you when you're there on the bridge.
你在文章中写道，当你在桥上时，他并不怎么跟你说话。
Yeah, he was really grumpy, and unwilling to acknowledge me.
是的，他脾气很暴躁，不愿理我。
And so, give me a typical exchange between the two of you on the bridge.
那么，给我描述一下你们在桥上的一次典型交流。
I think I did ask, like why are you standing here, as opposed to any other spot on this four-mile long bridge? And he turned and lifted his binoculars and focused out towards the river, and then brought his binoculars down, turned the other way, put his binoculars up and focused in the other direction on the crowd.
我想我问过，为什么你站在这里，而不是这座四英里长桥的其他地方？他转过身，举起望远镜对准河面，然后放下望远镜，转过身，又举起望远镜对准人群的方向。
Oh, that's it? He doesn't even respond?
哦，就这样？他甚至连回应都没有？
No, it was like I wasn't even there. It was like I was some ghost. And I sort of went through some of this and then I said, maybe, you know, is there a better time for us to talk? And he said to the translator, I can talk to you at lunch.
没有，就像我根本不存在一样。就像我是个鬼魂。我重复了几次，然后说，也许我们可以找个更好的时间谈谈？他告诉翻译，我可以在午餐时间跟你谈。
So you go to lunch with him, and what happens there?
所以你和他去吃午饭了，发生了什么？
Well, so we were in a little what they call family restaurant near the bridge, and there are no families present. I mean, it's just workers, and they're pretty hard-drinking. In this case, grain alcohol and beer. And so we sit down at the table, and Mr. Chen has invited a man to join us whose name is Mr. Shi. And then we are served some food, and Mr. Chen and Mr. Shi start really drinking a lot of grain alcohol. And I started to sort of drink with them, because it was the convivial thing to do. And then I just realized, I'm going to pass out if I try to stay with these guys, like I'm literally-- my head was spinning and I was-- you know, the whole room was revolving. I just was like-- and he was very disappointed, and so he sort of said, just, we're drinking here, this is what we do at lunch, and drinking loosens the tongue. And so get with the program, and if you can't, then why don't we-- you know, why don't you put on a dress.
我们在桥附近一家所谓的小型家庭餐馆，但根本没有家庭在场。全是工人在那儿，他们喝得很凶。在这种情况下，喝的是高粱酒和啤酒。我们坐在桌旁，陈先生邀请了一位叫史先生的人加入我们。然后菜上了，陈先生和史先生开始拼命喝高粱酒。我也开始试着陪他们喝，因为那样显得比较合群。然后我突然意识到，如果我继续陪他们喝，我就要晕倒了，我当时——头晕目眩，整个房间都在旋转。我当时想——他很失望，所以他说，我们在这儿喝酒，午饭就该这样，喝酒能让人敞开心扉。所以你就跟着节奏来，如果做不到，那要不你干脆穿上裙子算了。
But then he, at lunch he definitely opened up a little bit more. I mean, he wasn't looking at me when he answered questions, but he was answering them and he was speaking more expansively about life on the bridge.
但在午餐时，他确实稍微敞开了一点。我的意思是，他回答问题时没有看着我，但他确实回答了，并且更详细地谈论了桥上的生活。
Did he explain why it is that he does this?
他解释过为什么要这样做吗？
He said he had read a newspaper article about the bridge and about people jumping off the bridge, and he himself had grown up in the country outside of Naan-jing, so he really related, in particular, to these people from the villages who came to the bridge to end their lives and whose lives were hard and full of despair, and he completely understood that.
他说他读过一篇关于这座桥和人们跳桥的新闻报道，他自己是在南京郊区的农村长大的，所以他特别能感同身受，理解那些从农村来到桥上结束生命的人，他们生活艰难，充满绝望，他完全理解。
So you go back up to the bridge and he putters off in his moped, and then--
所以你回到桥上，他骑着他的助力车走开了，然后——
Yeah, and then he jumped on his moped to go on his rounds, and I didn't have anything to do, but I turned to the translator, Susan, and I said, hey, let's take a little walk out on the bridge. And so we started walking out over the bridge, and we're chatting a little bit, and this guy kind of came lurching by, and I didn't pay any attention to him, but this guy's about 20 feet, 30 feet ahead of us, and he seems to be climbing up on the railing.
是的，他骑上助力车去巡视了，我没什么事可做，但我转头对翻译苏珊说，嘿，我们去桥上走走吧。于是我们开始往桥上走，聊着天，有个家伙晃晃悠悠地经过，我没太在意，但他走在前面大概20到30英尺，看起来好像在爬围栏。
And, at that point, I just yelled, hey, and then I said to Susan, he's going to go over. And I started running for him, and Susan came running. And I had that one little flash of Mr. Chen saying, some of these people will really take you with them if they can. They're that desperate. And I had that little flash, like this would be a stupid way to die. This would be ridiculous if I go down with this guy, but it didn't come to that, because when I got to him I had my foot on the inside of the sort of the concrete buttress, and I tried to flip him back toward me. And he was completely limp. He was like a bag of sawdust. He just flipped right back on to me, and I hadn't even really pulled him that hard. It's hard to explain, but, like, when I think of it, I just get-- I have to say, I have just goosebumps all over my body right now.
就在那一刻，我喊了一声，嘿，然后我对苏珊说，他要跳下去了。我开始向他跑去，苏珊也跟了过来。我脑子里闪过陈先生说过的话：有些人如果可能的话，真会把你一起拉下去。他们就是那么绝望。我闪过一个念头，像这样死掉太蠢了。如果我和这个家伙一起掉下去简直是滑稽，但事情没到那一步，因为当我冲到他身边时，我一只脚踩在混凝土扶壁内侧，试图把他拽回来。他全身瘫软，就像一袋锯末。他直接向我倒过来，我甚至没怎么用力拉。很难解释，但每当我想到那一刻，我就——我不得不说，现在全身还起鸡皮疙瘩。
Because?
因为？
Because he was going to kill himself. And because he didn't.
因为他当时真的要自杀。也因为他没死成。
So did you feel good?
所以你感觉很好吗？
No, I didn't feel good. I felt like kind of nauseous. I felt like, wow, there, every week, somebody actually does this thing, and even if we were to clone Mr. Chen and there were 200 of him out there, they probably-- still, one a week, someone would figure out how to do it. And then, like, oh my god, who's coming next? You know?
不，我感觉不好。我觉得有点恶心。我觉得，哇，每周都有人真的这么做，即使我们克隆出200个陈先生在那里，他们可能——每周还是会有人找到办法跳下去。然后我就想，天哪，下一个会是谁？你知道吗？
And so Mr. Chen comes back, right?
然后陈先生回来了，对吧？
Yeah, well, it took Mr. Chen a while to come back on his moped, but when he came, when he showed up, the crowd sort of parted, and I was holding onto this man, whose name was Fan Ping. And he said to me, step away, which I thought was a really bad idea, because we're standing right next to the railing. But he had such command of the situation and all the nuances of the situation that I just stepped away. I just let go and stepped away. And then he said, I want to take your picture, which seemed like, you know-- I didn't even understand what that was about.
是的，陈先生骑着助力车回来花了一点时间，但他到的时候，人群自动让开了，我正抓着这个叫范平的人。他对我说，走开，我觉得这主意真够烂的，因为我们正站在扶栏边上。但他对情况的掌控力极强，对局势的所有细微之处都了如指掌，所以我只是走开了。我放开手走开了。然后他说，我要给你拍张照，这看起来——我甚至不明白这是什么意思。
He's taking a picture of the guy?
他给那个人拍照？
Yeah. So he pulls out his cell phone with a camera, takes a picture. And then he says, and now I think I should punch you in the face.
是的。他掏出带摄像头的手机，拍了张照。然后他说，现在我觉得我应该打你一拳。
Holy--
天哪——
And then he said, you call yourself Chinese. How dare you? How dare use call yourself Chinese, come up on this bridge with the intention of killing yourself today? You are somebody's son. How dare you? I am going to punch you in the face. I'm going to punch you right now. And the crowd, of course, is, like, crushing in because they think there's going to-- they think he's going to punch him. And I'm just sitting here like with my mouth open as he's saying this.
然后他说，你自称是中国人。你怎么敢？你怎么敢自称是中国人，今天来到这座桥上打算自杀？你是别人的儿子。你怎么敢？我要打你一拳。我现在就要打你。人群当然都挤了过来，因为他们以为——他们以为他真的要打人。我当时张大着嘴听着他这么说。
So he kind of takes another step in closer and Fan Ping says, look, I'm only doing this because my father was in the Red Army and he's lost all of his disability insurance, and there's no way for him to live anymore, and I'm a lousy son because I can't provide for him, and all of our documents burned in a fire, and without those documents we can't get any help. And Mr. Chen says, there nothing worth this. There's no problem that we can't solve.
他走近了一点，范平说，看，我这么做只是因为我父亲曾在红军服役，但他失去了所有的残疾保险，他没法活下去了，我是个不孝子，因为我没法供养他，我们所有的证件都在火灾中烧毁了，没有证件我们就没法得到任何救助。陈先生说，没有什么值得这样做的。没有什么问题是解决不了的。
And then he moves in a little bit closer and he touches his arm, just sort of holding him by the elbow with, like, his right hand. Mr. Chen says, I think I can help. I don't like this. I don't like what you're doing here. This isn't the way to solve anything. And, at that point, they have each other's word that they're going to meet on Monday morning at Mr. Chen's office.
然后他靠得更近一点，碰了碰他的胳膊，用右手抓着他的手肘。陈先生说，我想我能帮忙。我不喜欢这样。我不喜欢你在这儿做的事。这不是解决问题的方法。在那一点上，他们约定好周一早上在陈先生的办公室见面。
Do you get creeped out on any big bridge now?
你现在在任何大桥上会感到毛骨悚然吗？
Yeah. Well, obviously, after having been on the bridge, I started looking at bridges for their suicide potential. And every bridge is that bridge in Naan-jing, and every person is potentially Fan Ping, and every other person is potentially Mr. Chen. And you kind of look at it like, oh, I wonder if that is a bridge people would jump from. And I wonder if maybe someone should be out here.
会。显然，在去过那座桥之后，我开始观察每座桥的自杀潜力。每一座桥都像是南京那座，每个人都可能是范平，另外每个人都可能是陈先生。你就会看着桥想，哦，不知道这会不会是人们跳下去的桥。我不知道是不是有人应该在那儿看着。
Mike Paternini. His account of meeting Mr. Chen is in the current issue, the May issue, of GQ Magazine .
迈克·帕特里尼。他遇见陈先生的报道刊登在《GQ》杂志五月刊上。
[MUSIC - "THE BRIDGE" BY DOLLY PARTON].
[音乐 - 多莉·帕顿演唱的《桥》]
Act Two, Bridge and Tunnel.
第二幕，桥梁和隧道。
We've been talking about bridges so far in the show, but now we're going to turn to tunnel. Same idea, just underground. Tunnels are natural for smuggling, and there's a place that's in the midst of a kind of tunnel fever right now for smuggling, the Gaza Strip. Gaza's the piece of land, of course, on Israel's southwestern corner at the border of Egypt. About 1.5 million Palestinians live in Gaza.
节目到目前为止我们一直在谈论桥梁，但现在我们要转向隧道。同样的想法，只是在地下。隧道是走私的天然场所，现在有一个地方正处于某种隧道热中，就是加沙地带。加沙当然是位于以色列西南角、埃及边境的一块土地。大约有150万巴勒斯坦人住在加沙。
And Gaza has had smuggling tunnels for a long time. They were built years ago along the southern border of Gaza, the border it shares with Egypt, to bring in weapons. But in the last couple of years, after Hamas took control of Gaza, Israel has blockaded the goods that come in and out of Gaza, severely restricted, and so now all kinds of stuff is going through those tunnels. That's the tunnel fever.
加沙长期以来都有走私隧道。它们多年前沿着加沙南部与埃及的边界修建，用来运送武器。但在过去几年，哈马斯控制加沙后，以色列封锁了加沙的进出口物资，限制极其严苛，所以现在各种东西都通过这些隧道运输。这就是隧道热。
Nobody knows exactly how many tunnels there are now, hundreds, possibly 1,000, more being built every day. They've become central to Gaza's economy. One of our producers, Nancy Updike, recently moved to the Middle East. She says they're now how a lot of basic goods get into Gaza.
没人知道现在确切有多少隧道，几百条，可能有一千条，每天还在建新的。它们已经成为加沙经济的核心。我们的制片人之一南希·厄普代克最近搬到了中东。她说现在很多基本商品就是这样进入加沙的。
Clothing and flour and milk and cheese, cement, live animals, cigarettes, chocolate, oil, toothpaste, fish, prescription drugs, generators, computers, also gas and diesel, which are sometimes carried in by hand in cans, but are also pumped through the tunnels in these big hoses. There's an organization called PalTrade. It's this economic data gathering group. The World Bank quotes their statistics. And according to PalTrade, about 100,000 litres of gas, and another 100,000 litres of diesel are being pumped into Gaza every day through these tunnels.
衣服、面粉、牛奶和奶酪、水泥、活禽、香烟、巧克力、油、牙膏、鱼、处方药、发电机、电脑，还有汽油和柴油，有时是用罐子手工搬运进来的，但也会通过隧道用大软管泵送进来。有一个叫PalTrade的组织。这是一个经济数据收集小组。世界银行引用了他们的统计数据。据PalTrade称，每天约有10万升汽油和另外10万升柴油通过这些隧道泵入加沙。
The PalTrade guy, also, by the way, sent me a QuickTime video of a car, a whole car, being driven through one of the bigger tunnels in Gaza.
顺便说一句，PalTrade的那个人还给我发了一段QuickTime视频，显示一辆汽车，整辆车，被开过加沙的一条更大的隧道。
So Nancy, so you've talked to this guy who owns his own tunnel?
所以南希，你采访了一个拥有自己隧道的人？
Yeah, I read about people dying in the tunnels, and I made a phone call with the translator, just to see what we could find out. And we reached this guy who was very forthcoming. He talked to us for a couple of hours. He just kind of took us along with him on his errands. You can hear him in the background as he's walking around. There are cars honking, occasionally he talks to people he runs into. He puts us on hold a couple of times. We agreed to call him by a sort of classic Palestinian pseudonym, Abu Muhammad.
是的，我读过关于人们在隧道里死亡的报道，我找了个翻译打了个电话，想看看能了解什么。我们联系到了这个家伙，他非常配合。他跟我们谈了几个小时。他就像带着我们去跑腿一样。你在背景音里能听到他走来走去的声音。有汽车鸣笛声，偶尔他会和遇到的人说话。他几次让我们在线等待。我们同意使用一个经典的巴勒斯坦化名，阿布·穆罕默德。
And he started out by telling us about the first tunnel he worked on, not the one he owns himself now, but the very first tunnel he dug a few years ago.
他开始告诉我们关于他参与的第一条隧道，不是他现在拥有的那条，而是他几年前挖掘的第一条。
How long did it take to start building the tunnel and to finish it? How long did that take?
开始修建隧道到完工花了多长时间？花了多久？
[TRANSLATING IN ARABIC]?
[阿拉伯语翻译]？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
One whole year.
整整一年。
Did anyone die or get injured building the tunnel?
修建过程中有人死亡或受伤吗？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
Two died.
死了两个。
How did the people die?
人们是怎么死的？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
The first one died when the digging that we have being doing in the tunnel fell on him, buried him. Number one. And the second one died when the Egyptians put gas in such a way to poison the whole atmosphere.
第一个人死的时候是因为挖掘时隧道坍塌，把他活埋了。这是第一个。第二个死的时候是因为埃及人放入气体，把整个环境毒死了。
They did that to try to shut the tunnel down and stop the smuggling?
他们这样做是为了关闭隧道停止走私吗？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
It is a correct assumption on your part. This is why they did it. There was a time when we could not go inside out tunnel for three months. We had to evacuate it for three months in order for the gas to go out. Once it was out, we resumed work.
你的推测是对的。这就是他们这么做的原因。有段时间我们三个月都不能进隧道。我们不得不撤离三个月，好让气体散去。一旦气体散掉，我们就恢复工作。
And does the gas have a smell? How do you know that the gas is in the tunnel?
那种气体有味道吗？你怎么知道隧道里有气体？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
It does not have a smell. We find out in two ways: when people start fainting, losing consciousness, we know that the Egyptians have put this gas. Secondly, we find out about this gas from the amin. Amin means the person from whom we buy on the Egyptian side. He is the one who notifies us about the coming of the Egyptian officials and in terms of gas or other things. Sometimes they put bombs as well.
它没有味道。我们通过两种方式发现：当人们开始晕倒、失去知觉时，我们就知道埃及人放入了这种气体。其次，我们从“阿明”那里得知。阿明指的是我们在埃及一侧购买商品的对象。他负责通知我们埃及官员的情况，包括气体或其他动向。有时他们也会放炸弹。
So this is just very dangerous work?
所以这真是非常危险的工作？
Yes, lots of things can go wrong and do go wrong. I mean, since I've been here, I think there have been stories every single week about Palestinians dying in the tunnels. Just last week, four guys died in a tunnel. The Palestinians are accusing the Egyptians of gassing them. Egypt denies using gas in the tunnels ever. Tunnels sometimes collapse on their own. And there are always a lot men underground working in the tunnels. PalTrade, that organization I was talking about earlier, estimates that the tunnels employ 30,000 people.
是的，很多事情可能会出错，而且确实会出错。我的意思是，自从我在这里，我觉得每周都有关于巴勒斯坦人在隧道里死亡的报道。就在上周，四个人死在一条隧道里。巴勒斯坦人指责埃及人对他们投毒。埃及否认曾在隧道内使用过任何气体。隧道有时会自行坍塌。而且总有很多人在隧道地下工作。PalTrade，就是我之前提到的那个组织，估计隧道雇佣了3万人。
Oh my god.
哦，天哪。
Yeah. They don't all work underground, but there are a lot of people under the border between Gaza and Egypt at any given time.
是的。他们不全是在地下工作，但在任何时候，加沙和埃及边界下都有很多人。
How old were the people who died?
死的人多大年纪？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
One was 19 years old and one was 24 years old.
一个19岁，一个24岁。
When someone dies in the tunnel, is there any compensation to the family?
当有人在隧道里死亡时，有给家人的补偿吗？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
Yes, there is compensation. For a married man, the compensation is $11,000. For an unmarried man, for a bachelor, it's $9,000. These are the conditions put upon the tunnel owner. He has to comply with the government's laws and orders.
是的，有补偿。对于已婚男子，补偿是11000美元。对于未婚男子，也就是单身汉，是9000美元。这是对隧道业主提出的条件。他必须遵守政府的法律和命令。
So the government enforces the rule?
所以政府执行这条规定？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
This is correct.
没错。
So the government knows about this and the government has rules for this sort of thing?
所以政府知道这些，而且政府对这类事情有规定？
Absolutely. The government is Hamas in Gaza now, and it controls all of Gaza. And Hamas controls the tunnels. They own some of the tunnels outright and operate them themselves, but they control all of them. They shut them down when they want. They tax whatever goods they want at whatever rate they want. I've also heard about licensing fees the government's been charging to open tunnels, somewhere between $2,000 and $3,000.
当然。政府现在就是加沙的哈马斯，它控制着整个加沙。哈马斯控制着这些隧道。他们直接拥有一些隧道并亲自运营，但他们控制着所有隧道。他们想关就关。他们对任何想征税的商品按照他们想要的税率收税。我还听说过政府收取隧道开设许可费，大约在2000到3000美元之间。
Basically, what all this means is that smuggling through the tunnels in Gaza is becoming, in some ways, more and more a regular import/export point, taxes, licenses, regulations. It's nowhere near as regulated as an actual import/export would be, but these are holes in the ground covered by tents, just being dug by whoever can pull it off.
基本上，这意味着通过加沙隧道进行的走私在某些方面越来越像一个正式的进出口点，有税收、许可证、法规。它远没有真正的进出口受监管得那么严格，但这些不过是盖着帐篷的地面洞穴，由任何能搞定的人挖掘出来。
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
He has to disconnect for a very important issue for one minute.
他必须处理一件重要的事情，断线一分钟。
Oh, so he's putting us on hold?
哦，所以他让我们在线等待？
Putting us on hold. [PHONE BEEPING ON HOLD] [SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
在线等待。[电话通话保留提示音] [阿拉伯语]
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
There was a problem.
出了个问题。
What was the problem?
什么问题？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
I was notified that there was a problem with the electrical power inside the tunnel.
我收到通知说隧道里的电力出了问题。
Was the person calling to ask what he should do or to get permission to do something?
那个人打电话是问该怎么办，还是为了得到某种许可？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
I was told, I was asked to contact the person in charge of repairing the electricity. There was a breakdown in electricity at a time that my workers were bringing in merchandise.
我被告知，我被要求联系负责维修电力的人。在我的工人运送货物的时候出现了断电。
This guy started out a few years ago. He was 19 years old, and he was just another tunnel digger. And he said when he was digging it was 15 diggers at a time, making about $20 a day, working 12-hour shifts, six days a week. And once they're finished digging the tunnel, the workers get a percentage of what the tunnel brings in once it's operating as a smuggling operation.
这个家伙几年前刚开始的时候才19岁，只是个普通的隧道挖掘工。他说他挖掘的时候，15个人一起，每天赚20美元，轮班12小时，一周工作六天。一旦隧道挖好，工人就能从运营走私业务带来的收益中获得分成。
And it's $20 a day, is that a lot of money, a little money?
一天20美元，那是很多钱还是很少？
It's better than joining the 39% who are unemployed.
这总比加入那39%的失业大军强。
And so if I'm a laborer and I work in a tunnel, and then I get a percentage once the tunnel is functioning, like how much money can that mean?
所以如果我是个劳工，在隧道里干活，等隧道运营了我能拿到分成，那能拿到多少钱？
This guy said, when he started to get a percentage, he was making about $70 a day. That was his cut.
这个家伙说，当他开始拿到分成时，每天大概能赚70美元。这就是他的分成。
And he's getting that $70, not because he's working, carrying stuff through the tunnel, but simply for the work he did in building the tunnel?
他拿到这70美元不是因为他在搬东西，仅仅是因为他参与了隧道建设？
No, when the tunnel is finished being dug, then those workers become the workers who bring the goods through, so he is doing the work of bringing the goods through. He's still going to work for it, but it's a better wage for still a very difficult, dangerous job.
不，当隧道挖完后，这些工人就变成了搬运货物的工人，所以他依然在做搬运货物的工作。他还是靠劳动挣钱，但对于一份极其困难、危险的工作来说，这工资还算不错。
How did you make the transition from being a worker to owning your own tunnel?
你是怎么从工人过渡到自己拥有隧道的？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
I used to take a percentage from working in the tunnel. Then I sold my land, my family's land, in order to work more into the tunnels.
我以前在隧道打工拿提成。然后我卖了地，我家的地，为了能更多地参与到隧道里来。
Was that a big decision, something that you'd thought about for a long time?
那是一个重大决定吗，是你考虑很久的事情？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
It was a very difficult decision; however, there was no alternative to this. I had to do it.
这是一个非常困难的决定；然而，别无选择。我必须这么做。
So that's unusual, right?
那很罕见，对吧？
The translator and I were both very surprised when he said that he sold his family's land. This is not something that Palestinians do.
翻译和我听到他卖掉家里的地时都非常惊讶。这不是巴勒斯坦人会做的事情。
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
I started as a worker, and then I realized that more tunnels were being dug. And I also realized that the money I was getting as a worker was not enough. Therefore, I decided to do my own tunnel.
我从工人做起，然后我意识到有越来越多的隧道在挖。我还意识到我作为工人拿到的钱不够。因此，我决定自己挖隧道。
How big is your tunnel? Can you stand up in it? Can you touch the sides if you hold out your hands?
你的隧道有多大？你能站直吗？张开手能碰到墙壁吗？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC]. tunnel
[阿拉伯语] 隧道
My tunnel is 1.6 to 1.7 in height, 1.2 to 1.3 in width.
我的隧道高1.6到1.7米，宽1.2到1.3米。
Hey, Nancy, I'll just stop the tape there. What do those numbers mean?
嘿，南希，我就在那儿停下磁带。那些数字是什么意思？
It's 1.6 meters and 1.2 meters. 1.6 meters is just over five feet, and 1.2 meters is over three feet, almost four feet.
是1.6米和1.2米。1.6米略高于五英尺，1.2米超过三英尺，几乎四英尺。
Wait, wait, wait, so it's just over five feet tall and just over three feet wide? So this is, like, it's tiny.
等一下，等一下，也就是说它高五英尺多点，宽三英尺多点？所以这隧道，像，很小。
Yeah, there are tunnels of all different sizes. Some tunnels are massive. I mean, like I was saying earlier, there are tunnels you can drive a car through.
是的，有各种尺寸的隧道。有些隧道非常巨大。我的意思是，就像我刚才说的，有些隧道大到可以开车通过。
And how deep are the tunnels?
那隧道有多深？
Around 30 feet. It varies.
大约30英尺。深浅不一。
30 feet deep?
30英尺深？
Yeah, and, from what I've seen, there's sort of a swing that the guy sits on that's on a winch, and he's kind of lowered down into the tunnel.
是的，我见过有一种类似秋千的东西，人坐在上面，用绞盘下降到隧道里。
Excuse the personal question, but where do you go to the bathroom in the tunnel?
请原谅这个私人的问题，你在隧道里怎么上厕所？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
A worker, if he needs to urinate, then he can do it only in a bottle. However, if he needs to do much more than this, he has to leave the tunnel.
工人如果需要小便，只能用瓶子。但如果需要排便，他必须离开隧道。
Nancy, you're asking about that, like needing to use the bathroom, it occurs to me, somehow I pictured these tunnels being like, OK, they go, there's a tent, they go underneath it like a fence or something on the edge of, like, the border, and they come up right on the other side of the fence.
南希，你问那个关于上厕所的问题，我突然意识到，不知怎么我原先以为这些隧道是这样的：有一个帐篷，他们在边境线的栅栏下挖个洞，直接穿过，就到了栅栏的另一边。
No.
不。
Like, so they're not very far, but you saying this makes me realize, like, how far are these?
所以它们并不长，但你说这些让我意识到，这些隧道到底有多远？
Well, the length varies. I've heard of tunnels 250 feet, and others less than that. But it's not just popping under a fence. I mean, these guys are underground for a long time. This guy, Abu Muhammad, was saying that they have an intercom system set up, you know, what you would have in a multi-story house for the person on the first floor to talk to the person on the third floor. And as we were talking about his tunnel and how it operates, I asked the obvious question:
好吧，长度不等。我听说过250英尺长的隧道，也有比这短的。但不仅仅是穿过栅栏。我的意思是，这些家伙在地下待很长时间。这个叫阿布·穆罕默德的家伙说，他们设置了对讲系统，你知道，就是那种多层住宅里一楼跟三楼通话用的那种。当我们谈论他的隧道是如何运作时，我问了一个显而易见的问题：
Have you ever brought in weapons?
你曾经运送过武器吗？
[SPEAKING IN  ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
No.
没有。
Do you believe him that he hasn't ran any guns through the tunnel?
你相信他没通过隧道走私过枪支吗？
No, I think whatever people pay to bring in through the tunnels, he and everyone else brings in. And, again, Hamas is the one ultimately in control of the tunnels, so even though this guy owns his own tunnel, if Hamas wants to bring in weapons or cement or anything else, it's coming in through whichever tunnels they dictate. This guy, though, did go on to say something very surprising about weapons smuggling in the tunnels.
不，我想不管人们付钱要求运送什么，他和别人都会运送。而且再次强调，哈马斯是最终控制隧道的人，所以即使这家伙拥有自己的隧道，如果哈马斯想运进武器、水泥或其他任何东西，都会通过他们指定的隧道运进来。不过，这家伙确实说了一些关于隧道走私武器的非常令人惊讶的事情。
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
A strange thing happened concerning weapons. Because weapons are not allowed in the streets of Gaza, therefore there's no need to have weapons. So weapons became extremely cheap. What we have done is to transport weapons to Egypt. We are making $100 per weapon by selling it in Egypt, vice versa. And this, to me, is extremely strange.
关于武器发生了一件奇怪的事。因为加沙街头不允许有武器，所以根本不需要武器。因此武器变得极其便宜。我们所做的是把武器运到埃及。我们在埃及卖掉它，每把武器能赚100美元，反之亦然。这对我来说极其奇怪。
What weapons are you sending to Egypt?
你运往埃及的是什么武器？
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
We are sending guns and Kalashnikovs.
我们在运枪支和卡拉什尼科夫步枪。
Wait, wait, Nancy, so in other words, he's saying that they're not bringing weapons into Gaza, basically, they're exporting weapons from Gaza into Egypt and making a profit?
等等，南希，换句话说，他在说他们不是把武器运进加沙，基本上，他们是在把武器从加沙出口到埃及并从中获利？
Well, he's saying that's what he's doing. And, again, I don't know. He may be bringing weapons in, too. But I believe him that he's also sending them out.
嗯，他是说这是他在做的。再一次声明，我不知道。他可能也在运进武器。但我相信他确实也在把武器运出去。
So this guy's making this huge economic gamble. He's selling off his family's land to invest in this tunnel. Is it working for him? Is he getting rich?
所以这家伙在做这种巨大的经济豪赌。他卖掉了家里的地来投资这条隧道。对他来说成功了吗？他发财了吗？
Well, here's what he said.
嗯，这是他说的。
[SPEAKING IN ARABIC].
[阿拉伯语]
Before, we used to make between $5,000 to $10,000 dollars a month. And the money we were making was good. But now it has decreased from $5,000 to $1,500 a month. Now there's an abundance of tunnels all over the area. And therefore, the work has not become unique. There's a lot of tunnels, and therefore, you make less money.
以前，我们一个月能赚5000到10000美元。那时候赚的钱很好。但现在已经从5000降到了1500美元一个月。现在整个地区到处都是隧道。因此，这项工作不再稀缺。隧道太多了，所以赚的钱就少了。
Nancy, doesn't he face one other economic risk, and that is that if there were peace, if peace would break out between the Israelis and the Palestinians, these tunnels wouldn't have a reason to exist, and his whole investment would go to hell? Does he worry at all about peace?
南希，他难道不面临另一个经济风险吗？那就是如果和平到来，如果以色列人和巴勒斯坦人之间爆发和平，这些隧道就失去了存在的理由，他的全部投资都将化为泡影？他担心和平吗？
I didn't ask him, but I don't think he's worried about peace. I think he's a lot more worried about his tunnel collapsing than he's worried about Israel making peace with Hamas.
我没问过他，但我不认为他在担心和平。我觉得他比担心以色列和哈马斯实现和平，更担心他的隧道坍塌。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, city and county laws that force possibly dangerous ex-cons to be homeless and move under a bridge. If I asked you to guess which state, which sunny, sunny state would do that, which would you guess? Answers in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来的节目，地方法律迫使可能危险的前罪犯无家可归，不得不搬到桥下。如果我让你猜是哪个州，哪个阳光明媚的州会这么做，你会猜哪个？来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
This is This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week in our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, the bridge, stories of people living at various bridges of various sorts. We have arrived at act three of our show.
这是《这美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目是关于桥梁，关于居住在各种桥梁上的人们的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Throw the Book at Them.
第三幕，严厉惩处。
This next story takes place under a bridge. You may have heard about this bridge, where a bunch of ex-cons, sex offenders, set up camp in Miami.
下一个故事发生在桥下。你可能听说过这座桥，一群前罪犯、性犯罪者在迈阿密这里安营扎寨。
South Florida is known for sun, sand, and surf, but the welcoming committee on your Miami beach is now this: convicted sex offenders. They are pitching tents and camping out by the Julia Tuttle Causeway.
南佛罗里达以阳光、沙滩和冲浪闻名，但迈阿密海滩的欢迎委员会现在成了这副模样：被定罪的性犯罪者。他们在朱莉娅·塔特尔堤道边搭起了帐篷露营。
You may have seen them when you drive by and wondered why they're there.
你开车经过时可能看到过他们，会纳闷为什么他们在那儿。
Why they're there is because, in 2005, Miami Dade County passed a law that required sex offenders who were coming out of jail to find housing at least 2,500 feet from any school, playground, or daycare. You probably heard about these residency restriction laws. Communities all over the country have them, but Miami's was, at the time, probably the strictest law of its kind.
为什么在那儿是因为，2005年，迈阿密戴德县通过了一项法律，要求刚出狱的性犯罪者寻找距离学校、游乐场或日托中心至少2500英尺的住房。你可能听说过这些居住限制法。全国各地的社区都有这种规定，但迈阿密当时的法律可能是同类中最严厉的。
If you think about it, 2,500 feet, that's half a mile, eight football fields, in a densely packed city, from any school, park, or daycare. The entire city of Miami Beach, one of the cities that's in that county, is barely a mile wide at its widest point, was now effectively off limits to sex offenders, which its mayor acknowledged. So under this bridge was one of the few spots that sex offenders in Dade County could legally live.
想想看，2500英尺，就是半英里，八个足球场，在一个人口稠密的城市里，距离任何学校、公园或日托中心。整个迈阿密海滩市，县里其中一个城市，最宽处也只有一英里宽，现在实际上对性犯罪者来说是禁区，市长也承认了这一点。所以这座桥下成了戴德县性犯罪者唯一能合法居住的地方之一。
Isaiah Thompson broke this story in 2007 for the Miami New Times . He's been closely following it ever since. He says the fact that they ended up at the bridge is really just the beginning.
以赛亚·汤普森在2007年为《迈阿密新时报》报道了这个新闻。此后他一直密切关注此事。他说他们最终住在桥下仅仅是个开始。
What's happened under this bridge all came to pass because of one man, and he's probably the only one who can fix it, too. He's a man with a mission, and his job is to get missions done, Ron Book.
在这座桥下发生的一切都是因为一个人，他可能也是唯一能解决问题的人。他是一个有使命的人，他的工作就是完成任务，罗恩·布克。
I use my soap box. I use my forum. I use my skills. I have a skill set that makes me the number-one ranked guy in this business.
我利用我的发言权。我利用我的平台。我利用我的技能。我拥有一套技能，使我在这个行业中排名第一。
Ron Book's business is lobbying. He's one of the most powerful and influential lobbyists in Florida, a man who refers to the local sheriff as my sheriff, and the state attorney as my state attorney. He can be charming and gracious, but when he has a point to make, he doesn't hold back.
罗恩·布克的职业是游说。他是佛罗里达州最有权势、最有影响力的游说者之一，一个把当地警长称为“我的警长”，把州检察官称为“我的州检察官”的人。他可以很迷人、很优雅，但当他有观点要表达时，他绝不退缩。
See that sign? See that sign right there?
看到那个牌子了吗？看到那个牌子了吗？
He points to two plaques on a wall that's otherwise covered with awards and pictures of him shaking hands with famous people.
他指向墙上的两块牌匾，墙上其余部分挂满了奖状和他与名人握手的照片。
See that sign right there? It says it can be done. See that sign? Nothing is impossible. What sets me out from the others is I'm driven. What sets me out from the others is I've got more passion. What sets me out from the others is I get up earlier than most everybody else in this business and I stay up later and I get it done. Don't take my word for it. Go out there and ask my colleagues. Pick up the phone, call the other five or six or eight super-lobbyists in this business, and ask them who works harder than anybody else. That's what sets me out.
看到那个牌子了吗？上面写着“可以做到”。看到那个牌子了吗？“没有什么是不可能的”。让我与众不同的是我的驱动力。让我与众不同的是我有更多的热情。让我与众不同的是我比这个行业里的大多数人都起得更早，我睡得更晚，而且我能搞定。别只听我一面之词。出去问问我的同行。拿起电话，打给这个行业里其他五六个超级游说者，问问他们谁比别人更努力工作。这就是让我与众不同的地方。
I'm tenacious. I'm nasty if I have to be nasty. I'm firm if I gotta be firm. I'm direct if I gotta be direct. You know, my job is to get it done. And right now, right now, the victims of sexual abuse, the victims of sexual assault, got a guy who is the worst enemy of abusers and offenders and predators and pedophiles, because I am obsessed, because I will spend the rest of my life working to protect people. That's my job. That's my job.
我很顽强。如果有必要我很恶劣。如果必须坚定我就很坚定。如果必须直接我就很直接。你知道，我的工作就是把事情搞定。现在，此刻，性虐待的受害者，性侵犯的受害者，有一个敌人是虐待者、犯罪者、捕食者和恋童癖者的最大克星，因为我着了迷，因为我余生都将致力于保护人们。那是我的工作。那是我的工作。
Why is it my job? It's my job because, unfortunately for me, I have a daughter who suffered at the hands of a no-good-for-nothing, no-good-for-nothing, no redeeming qualities, no redeeming social values, no redeeming humanistic values, who raped my daughter, who beat my daughter. I am the predators' and offenders' worst enemy. I am their worst nightmare, and I will be that forever until the day I die when they put me in a pine box and put me in the ground.
为什么这是我的工作？因为不幸的是，我有个女儿，她落入了一个一无是处、毫无救药、没有任何救赎价值、没有任何社交价值、没有任何人性价值的家伙手中，他强奸了我的女儿，毒打了我的女儿。我是这些捕食者和犯罪者的最大敌人。我是他们最可怕的噩梦，我会一直这样下去，直到我死的那天，他们把我装进松木盒埋入地下。
Around 15 years ago, Ron Book hired a nanny who started molesting his daughter. It's an awful story. The nanny was arrested, brought to trial, and sent to prison, but that was just the beginning for Book. When he found out there was no law compelling convicted sex offenders to provide blood samples for HIV tests, he wrote one and got it passed. When the nanny started writing letters to his daughter from prison, and Book found out there was no law explicitly against it, he simply went ahead and got that law passed, too. It's now called the Lauren Book Protection Act, after his daughter.
大约15年前，罗恩·布克雇了一个保姆，开始猥亵他的女儿。那是一个可怕的故事。保姆被逮捕、受审并送进监狱，但这只是布克的开始。当他发现没有法律强制要求被定罪的性犯罪者提供血液样本进行艾滋病测试时，他起草了一项法案并获通过。当那个保姆开始从监狱写信给他女儿，而布克发现没有法律明确禁止时，他又直接推动通过了那项法律。现在以他女儿的名字命名，称为《劳伦·布克保护法》。
But Book didn't stop there. He and his daughter went on a kind of tour of Florida, pushing residency restrictions. In 2005, he helped write and pass the law in Miami Dade County that required sex offenders to find housing at least 2,500 feet from any school, playground, or daycare, leaving sex offenders with very few places to live. They ended up under that bridge, homeless.
但布克并没有就此停止。他和女儿在佛罗里达州做了一次巡回演讲，推动居住限制。2005年，他帮助起草并推动迈阿密戴德县通过了那项法律，要求性犯罪者找到距离任何学校、游乐场或日托中心至少2500英尺的住房，让性犯罪者几乎无处可住。他们最终流落到那座桥下，无家可归。
And the person in Miami Dade that's in charge of helping homeless people like these find homes and jobs, the person with the resources, the manpower, and a budget of $40 million to help them also happens to be Ron Book.
而在迈阿密戴德县负责帮助像他们这样的无家可归者寻找住房和工作的人，拥有资源、人力和4000万美元帮助预算的人，恰好也是罗恩·布克。
I am chairman of the Miami Dade County Homeless Trust. I have been the chairman of this body for 16 years. This particular population is a piece of the homeless population and I have a responsibility to find them housing and jobs. That's what my homeless trust does. And these guys are a component of that.
我是迈阿密戴德县无家可归者信托基金的主席。我已经担任该机构主席16年了。这个特定群体是无家可归者的一部分，我有责任为他们寻找住房和工作。这就是我的信托基金所做的。这些人是其中的一部分。
So the one person who could possibly help the sex offenders find a place to live is their biggest enemy, the person who got them there in the first place.
所以唯一能帮助性犯罪者找到住处的人，竟然是他们最大的敌人，也就是最初把他们推到这一步的那个人。
[CAR DRIVING] For as much press as this bridge has gotten, it's surprisingly hard to find.
[开车声]尽管这座桥得到了很多媒体报道，但要找到它出奇地难。
We're looking out for some kind of opening in the fence here. You're going to have to-- we might miss it the first time, because we're going so fast.
我们得找这里围栏的一个开口。你得——我们可能会错过第一次，因为我们开得太快了。
My producer and I drove there one late and particularly cold night in February. The bridge is part of a six-lane highway, the Julia Tuttle Causeway, which crosses the Biscayne Bay.
我和我的制片人在二月一个深夜，在那天特别冷的时候开车过去。这座桥是六车道公路的一部分，朱莉娅·塔特尔堤道，它横跨比斯坎湾。
Put on your turn signal and then see if you can get over. I know it sounds crazy.
打上转向灯，看看能不能拐过去。我知道听起来很疯狂。
And drive on the shoulder?
开上路肩？
Yeah, drive on the shoulder.
对，开上路肩。
God, it's hard to do this in the dark.
天哪，在黑暗中做这个太难了。
Wait, wait, wait, what's this? Yeah, this is it. This is it. Go slow, because it's real rough terrain.
等等，等等，这是什么？是的，就是这里。就是这里。慢点开，地形真的很崎岖。
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
We're on a tiny island in the middle of the bay. It's about a mile long, until recently, uninhabited. There are no exits on to the island, just a narrow opening in the guard rails, just before you get to the bridge, and a bumpy dirt path that leads underneath it. Here, hidden from the traffic above, we find a kind of post-apocalyptic outpost, scattered between the giant concrete columns that hold the bridge up are half a dozen wooden shanties, bicycles, and a makeshift fishing peer, a mound of rotting trash. Tents that have been fitted out with lights and furniture are tucked into little concrete alcoves high above us, in the rafters of the bridge, as if a particularly modern group of cavemen lived here.
我们来到了海湾中间的一个小岛上。它大约有一英里长，直到最近还没人居住。岛上没有出口，只有护栏上的一个狭窄开口，就在桥的前面，还有一条颠簸的土路通往桥下。在这里，避开了上方的车流，我们发现了一个类似末日后的前哨站，散落在支撑桥梁的巨大混凝土柱之间的是半打木棚、自行车和一个简易的钓鱼码头，还有一堆腐烂的垃圾。 fitted fittedfitted fitted fitting fitting fitting. 帐篷配备了灯光和家具，塞进我们上方高处的小混凝土凹槽里，在桥的椽子里，仿佛一群特别现代的穴居人住在这里。
The roar of electric generators blocks out almost every sound but the cars whooshing across the bridge overhead.
发电机的轰鸣声掩盖了除桥上方呼啸而过的汽车以外的几乎所有声音。
Hello, Patrick. It's Isaiah. I first met Patrick Wiese three years ago, sleeping in a cardboard box. Patrick had just come out of prison, where he'd spent two years and received 10 more years probation for molesting his nine-year-old stepdaughter, a charge to which he pled guilty after turning himself into the police at his wife's request. Considering his circumstances, what was surprising wasn't so much that he had ended up living in a box under a bridge, but how he had come to be right there precisely.
你好，帕特里克。我是以赛亚。我三年前第一次见到帕特里克·维斯时，他正睡在一个纸箱里。帕特里克刚出狱，他在监狱里待了两年，又因为猥亵9岁的继女被判了10年缓刑，他在妻子的要求下向警方自首后对指控认罪。考虑到他的处境，令人惊讶的不是他最终住在桥下的一个盒子里，而是他怎么会精准地在那儿。
His probation officer, he said, had ordered him to live there.
他说，他的缓刑官命令他住在那儿。
I had a woman probation officer at that time, and she told me that I have to live underneath a bridge. I said, wait a minute, you're going to make me homeless? This is crazy. And she let me out the door, told me I have to be there by 10 o'clock at night. So for two or three months I lived, basically, out of a cardboard box.
那时我有一个女性缓刑官，她告诉我我必须住在桥下。我说，等一下，你要让我无家可归吗？这太疯狂了。她让我出门，告诉我必须在晚上10点前赶到那儿。所以两三个月里，我基本上就住在一个纸箱里。
For proof, Patrick extracted a few ratty sheets of paper. One was an official document, a department of corrections letterhead, indicating Patrick's address. Bridge, it said. There are a handful of other places to live 2,500 feet from schools, playground, and daycare centers in the county. They include expensive gated communities most ex-cons can't afford, and the Everglades, where it's illegal to live, and a random apartment building here or there, but they're few and far between. So here's Patrick today. He has a girlfriend and a cell phone, and for a while, a job working at a sub shop making sandwiches.
为了证明，帕特里克拿出几张破旧的纸。其中一份是正式文件，惩教部门的信头，上面写着帕特里克的地址。桥，上面写着。县里距离学校、游乐场和日托中心2500英尺的地方屈指可数。它们包括大多数前罪犯买不起的高档封闭式社区，还有法律规定禁止居住的大沼泽地，以及零星分布的公寓楼，但它们非常少见。这就是现在的帕特里克。他有一个女朋友和一部手机，有一阵子，还在一家三明治店工作。
And I've been here almost three years now. When I first came down here I had nothing. I acquired a tent, and I lived up on underneath the bridge. Now, I lived there for a little over a year in one tent. In that year's time, I accumulated, let's see, a TV, lighting, a generator. As you can see, I have my radio. I have my DVD player. Right here is my shower. It has like a--
我已经在这儿快三年了。我刚来这里时什么都没有。我弄了个帐篷，住到桥下。我在那个帐篷里住了一年多。那一年里，我攒下了，你看，一台电视机、照明设备、一台发电机。正如你所看到的，我有我的收音机。我有我的DVD播放机。这就是我的淋浴器。它有一个——
Wow.
哇。
--a hot bag. What that is a thermal shower. You fill it up with water, you put it in the sun for two hours and it heats up, so you have hot water instead of taking a cold shower. You know, the essentials.
——一个热水袋。那是一个热能淋浴器。你把它装满水，放在太阳下晒两个小时它就热了，所以你就有热水洗澡，不用洗冷水澡。你知道，都是必需品。
What began as three men living here became a kind of colony, a microcivilization. Tonight, it's nearing most people's curfew, 10 o'clock. An occasional car pulls in under the bridge, briefly lighting the place up and then rumbling off to park somewhere by the water. Other than that, it's dark and seedy. An occasional cigarette cherry reveals people hunkered down in the shadows, talking quietly, drinking.
最初只有三个人住在这里，后来变成了一个类似殖民地的微型文明。今晚，快到大多数人的宵禁时间了，晚上10点。偶尔有汽车开进桥下，短暂地照亮这里，然后隆隆地停在水边。除此以外，这里一片漆黑，阴森森的。偶尔闪烁的烟头火光显露出蜷缩在阴影中人们的身影，低声交谈，喝酒。
Sex offenders getting out of prison are dropped off here like it's the most normal thing in the world. Voncel Johnson ended up under the Julia Tuttle Causeway in 2009. She walks up to us in slippers and a bathrobe.
刚出狱的性犯罪者被送到这里，仿佛这是世界上最正常的事情。冯塞尔·约翰逊2009年最终来到朱莉娅·塔特尔堤道下。她穿着拖鞋和睡袍走近我们。
When I got out of prison, I go-- they told me to go screening report to my probation officer, so I go to her. She tell me, well, I'm sorry, Ms. Johnson, you can't go live where you were supposed to live at. Now I have to go to the Julia Causeway bridge like, what the [BLEEP] is that? I'm thinking, it's OK, it's a treatment. You know, I didn't know.
当我出狱时，他们让我去向我的缓刑官报到，所以我去了。她告诉我，好吧，对不起，约翰逊女士，你不能去你原定该住的地方了。现在我必须去朱莉娅堤道桥，这是什么[哔]东西？我想，没关系，这是一种治疗。你知道，我不知道。
So, in other words, you thought that the bridge was actually just the name of like a halfway house or a treatment.
所以换句话说，你以为桥只是半途之家或某种治疗中心的名字。
Yes, I was thinking it's a treatment center or something. I didn't know the difference. I'm saying, and then you bring me down on this bridge. He just told me and aunty to follow behind her, and she was going to take us to this place.
是的，我以为是一个治疗中心什么的。我不知道区别。我说，然后你把我带到这座桥上。他只是告诉我，让我跟在她后面，她会把我们带到这个地方。
So you actually, the night that you showed up, she was with you, your probation officer?
所以你到达的那天晚上，她和你在一起，你的缓刑官？
My probation officer brought me here and told me it's going to be OK. Here it is about 10 o'clock at night, it's pitch dark here, no lights. I see a 1,000 people coming up to my aunt's car like, are you going to be OK? No, I'm not going to be OK. I broke down. I almost had a nervous breakdown. I told her I'd rather go back to prison and do my time and then get out and go where I can live. But they told me I can't do that. I have to sleep under this bridge.
我的缓刑官把我带到这里，说会没事的。当时大概是晚上10点，这里一片漆黑，没有灯。我看到1000个人走向我阿姨的车，说，你们会没事的吗？不，我不会没事。我崩溃了。我差点精神崩溃。我告诉她我宁愿回到监狱坐牢，然后再出来去我能住的地方。但他们告诉我我不行。我必须住在这座桥下。
Like Voncel, a lot of the people living under the bridge have family more than willing to take them in, but whose addresses don't comply with the law. From the start, there were questions about whether the 2,500-foot rule that put all these people under this bridge actually accomplished what it was originally supposed to do, which was protect children. For example, the law only restricts where sex offenders sleep, literally between the hours of 10 at night and 6 in the morning, when no kids are on the street, anyway. They're free to come and go during the day.
像冯塞尔一样，住在桥下的很多人都有非常愿意接收他们的家人，但他们的地址不符合法律规定。从一开始，人们就质疑那个把这些人全部推到这座桥下的2500英尺规定是否真的达到了它原本的目的，也就是保护孩子。例如，法律仅限制性犯罪者睡觉的地点，确切地说是晚上10点到凌晨6点之间，那时根本没有孩子在街上。他们白天可以自由出入。
Some of them spend the day back at their own houses with their families, including their kids. Jill Levenson is a researcher and social worker at Lynn University in Boca Raton, who specialized in studying sex offender policy, and is as close to a nemesis as Ron Book has in Florida. She says researchers have studied residency restrictions all over the country.
他们中有一些人白天会回到自己的家里陪家人，包括他们的孩子。吉尔·列文森是博卡拉顿林恩大学的研究员和社会工作者，专门研究性犯罪者政策，她是佛罗里达州罗恩·布克的死对头。她说研究人员研究了全国各地的居住限制。
From Florida, Minnesota, Colorado, New Mexico, Nevada, New Jersey, New York, Iowa, their conclusions about residence restrictions are remarkably consistent. The results are consistently that there is no relationship between where a sex offender lives and whether or not he reoffends. Sex offenders who live closer to schools or parks or daycare centers do not reabuse children more often than those who live farther away.
从佛罗里达、明尼苏达、科罗拉多、新墨西哥、内华达、新泽西、纽约、爱荷华，他们关于居住限制的结论非常一致。结果始终是，性犯罪者的居住地点与是否再次犯罪之间没有关联。居住在离学校、公园或日托中心更近的性犯罪者，并不比居住在较远地方的人更常虐待儿童。
Meanwhile, the practical difficulties of housing the sex offenders was gumming up the works at a number of government agencies, who began pointing fingers at each other and suing. Maria Kayanan from the ACLU represents a number of the former residents from the bridge.
与此同时，安置性犯罪者的实际困难拖慢了许多政府机构的工作，他们开始互相指责并诉讼。美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）的玛丽亚·卡亚南代表了许多从桥上搬走的前住户。
Everybody blames everybody else. The Department of Corrections blames the County for its residency restriction. The County blames the Department of Corrections for having its probation officers tell released offenders that there's no place for them to live in the county other than the Julia Tuttle Causeway. The City of Miami sued the Department of Corrections, the Department of Transportation, and the Department of Motor Vehicle Safety and Licensing-- I may have that backwards-- because they were putting Julia Tuttle Causeway as the official addresses on folks' driver's license and ID cards.
每个人都责怪别人。惩教部责怪县政府实行居住限制。县政府责怪惩教部，因为他们的缓刑官告诉被释放的罪犯，除了朱莉娅·塔特尔堤道外，县里没有别的地方可以去。迈阿密市起诉了惩教部、交通部和机动车辆安全与许可部门——我可能记反了——因为他们把朱莉娅·塔特尔堤道作为这些人驾驶执照和身份证件上的官方地址。
So you're saying the City of Miami sued the DMV for putting Julia Tuttle Causeway on driver's license.
所以你是说迈阿密市起诉机动车管理局在驾照上印朱莉娅·塔特尔堤道地址。
That's right. It's like, if we click our heels together three times and just make their ZIP codes a string of zeroes, the problem will go away.
没错。就像如果我们像童话里一样磕三次脚后跟，让他们的邮政编码变成一串零，问题就会消失一样。
As government agencies struggle with all the repercussions of the rule, officials who are pointing fingers at each other started to point them at Ron Book, the man who got them into this mess and the man with the connections to fix it. And Ron stepped into the fray, happy to lead the charge. Again, Maria Kayanan of the ACLU.
随着政府机构与该规定的所有后果作斗争，那些互相指责的官员开始把矛头指向罗恩·布克，那个把他们带进这个麻烦，并拥有解决它的人脉的人。罗恩也加入了争斗，乐于带头冲锋。还是那位ACLU的玛丽亚·卡亚南。
I just know that he is a force of nature. When he speaks, when he appears, he commands the room. He is omnipresent. No matter whether it's a county commission hearing, whether it's a court hearing, whether it was in our litigation or the city's litigation, [SMACKS THE TABLE] there he was with this Italian suit.
我只知道他是一股自然力量。当他说话，当他出现，他统领整个房间。他无处不在。不管是在县委员会听证会，还是在法院听证会，无论是在我们的诉讼还是市政府的诉讼中，[拍打桌子]他穿着那身意大利西装就出现了。
The most obvious way to fix the problem at the bridge would be for Ron Book to go back to the legislators who originally passed the 2,500-foot rule and roll it back, and that's something Ron is uniquely qualified to make happen. But that's the one thing that's off the table, as far as Ron Book is concerned. He stands by the 2,500-foot rule. In fact, he won't even admit it's the reason people moved under the bridge in the first place, an issue I've been arguing with him going on three years now.
解决桥上问题的最明显方法是让罗恩·布克回去找当初通过2500英尺规定的立法者并撤销它，而罗恩完全有能力做到这一点。但这是罗恩·布克关心的唯一不能谈的话题。他坚持2500英尺的规定。事实上，他甚至不承认这是人们最初搬到桥下的原因，我和他就这个问题争论了三年了。
I don't believe the ordinance made them homeless. I don't believe the ordinance put them under the Julia Tuttle Causeway. I disagree that the ordinance put them there. Their crimes put them there. Their crimes put them their Their unemployability put them there. Their lack of financial resources put them there. I don't truly believe 2,500 feet made them there. And I will not--
我不相信这项法令让他们无家可归。我不相信该法令把他们推到了朱莉娅·塔特尔堤道下。我不同意该法令把他们放在那儿。是他们的罪行把他们放在那儿。是他们的罪行。他们的就业能力把他们放在那儿。他们的经济资源缺乏把他们放在那儿。我真的不相信2500英尺让他们呆在那里。而且我不会——
That's crazy, Ron. There was no one living under the Julia Causeway.
这太疯狂了，罗恩。根本没人住在朱莉娅堤道下。
You're not going to get me to accept that, because I don't, I don't. As a premise, I just don't.
你没法让我接受这个观点，因为我不接受。作为一个前提，我就是不接受。
And so, instead, Book concocted a complicated and fabulously expensive plan, using the resources and staff time at his disposal as the head of the Miami Dade Homeless Trust as well as federal stimulus dollars meant primarily for housing people made homeless by the recession and the foreclosure crisis. His staff began working full-time, trying to move the sex offenders one by one into any legal housing they could find.
所以，布克制定了一个复杂且极其昂贵的计划，利用他作为迈阿密戴德县无家可归者信托基金负责人的资源和员工时间，以及主要用于安置受经济衰退和丧失抵押品赎回权危机影响而无家可归者的联邦刺激资金。他的工作人员开始全职工作，试图把这些性犯罪者一个个安置到他们能找到的任何合法住处。
I will promise you this, that it is the 19 of February-- and I know that I told you this place was going to be closed a little sooner than now-- I assure you that you get to be the 1 of April, the 15 of April, there won't be any more people there. There'll be a piece of guardrail up on the eastbound side and a piece of guardrail up on the westbound side. They're not going to be able drive their cars down there anymore. And those people that continue to have a registration address under the Julia Tuttle Causeway will likely have their doors knocked on and they will be taken back to jail for violating the law.
我向你保证，今天是2月19日——我知道我告诉过你这个地方会比现在早一点关闭——我向你保证，到4月1日，4月15日，那儿就不会再有人了。往东的一侧会装上一块护栏，往西的一侧也会装上一块护栏。他们将无法再把车开到那儿去。那些继续把朱莉娅·塔特尔堤道作为登记地址的人，很可能会被敲门，并因为违反法律而被带回监狱。
On April 1, The Miami Herald reported that the bridge, at last, had been cleared out. All Sex Offenders from Miami's Shanty Town in Housing, said the headline. It was over, except it wasn't over. The day after the bridge had been cleared out, some 30 sex offenders who Book's people had moved into a hotel by the airport were suddenly evicted when one of the men living there was arrested for lewd and lascivious molestation of a minor.
4月1日，《迈阿密先驱报》报道说，桥终于清理干净了。头条标题是“迈阿密贫民窟的所有性犯罪者已安置住房”。一切结束了，除了它并没有结束。桥被清理干净的第二天，布克的人安置在机场附近一家酒店的一些性犯罪者突然被驱逐，因为其中一名住在那里的男子因对未成年人进行猥亵和淫秽骚扰被捕。
Just two days after the bridge had been cleared out for good, its former residents were sleeping on the floor of their probation offices. Asked if some of the men will be going back under the bridge, Book told reporters, that is not an option. So where were they supposed to go? And where were other sex offenders coming out of prison this year and next year supposed to go? The few pockets of Miami Dade County that had housing that complied with the 2,500-foot rule were already filling up disproportionately with sex offenders.
就在桥被彻底清理干净两天后，其前住户正睡在缓刑办公室的地板上。当被问及这些人中是否有一些会回到桥下时，布克告诉记者，那不是一个选项。那么他们该去哪儿？今年和明年出狱的其他性犯罪者该去哪儿？迈阿密戴德县那几个符合2500英尺规定的住房点，已经不成比例地挤满了性犯罪者。
Mucking through the sex offender database, I stumbled on a little patch of houses in the middle of miles of farmland, in the middle of nowhere, where, according to the most recent count, 14 sex offenders live alongside families with children. By now, Ron Book has to see all the trouble the 2,500-foot rule is causing. At every turn, he's responded to events by taking on even more responsibility for the lives of these sex offenders. Now he's their landlord, their lawmaker, the arbiter over their fate. But as things have gone wrong, Book has refused to back down or lose face. There have been a few attempts to clean up the current mess by forcing every community in Florida to obey the same statewide residency restriction of 1,000 feet, or maybe 1,500 feet.
在性犯罪者数据库里翻找时，我在荒芜的农田中 stumbled 发现了一小片房屋，根据最新统计，14名性犯罪者与有孩子的家庭住在一起。到目前为止，罗恩·布克一定看到了2500英尺规定造成的麻烦。他在每一个关头都通过承担更多这些性犯罪者生活的责任来回应事件。现在他是他们的房东、立法者、他们命运的裁决者。但随着事情出错，布克拒绝退让或丢脸。有一些试图通过迫使佛罗里达州的每个社区都遵守同样1000英尺，或者也许1500英尺的州居住限制来清理当前烂摊子的尝试。
Book says that's not good enough, throwing numbers out like he's bargaining for a car. 1,750, he'll sometimes say, might be OK for other communities, not his though. For Book, for Book's community, only 2,500 will do.
布克说那还不够好，抛出数字就像他在讨价还价买车一样。1750，他有时会说，可能对其他社区可以，但他的不行。对于布克，对于布克的社区，只有2500才行。
There's a rational, responsible distance somewhere between 1,750 feet and 2,500 feet.
在1750英尺到2500英尺之间一定有一个合理的、负责任的距离。
What's the difference? It's 250 feet. I mean, what difference does it make?
有什么区别？只有250英尺。我的意思是，那有什么区别？
It's another football field away. And when one looks at 1,000 feet, it's three football fields. Well, I can see three football fields. You're in my 10th floor office having this interview with me. I can see three football fields right now. I can see children three football fields away. I have a powerful set of binoculars I will show you on your way out of my office. I could see five football fields with those binoculars. I don't want a predator and offender, somebody convicted, that has been determined to have committed sexually deviant acts on our children, I do not want that person looking out of their bedroom windows, out of their living room windows, down into a park, down into a playground, that had this person who has a predilection to offend against a child scouting out their next victim.
那是另一个足球场的距离。如果你看1000英尺，那是三个足球场。嗯，我能看到三个足球场。你现在正在我10楼的办公室采访我。我现在就能看到三个足球场。我能看到三个足球场外的孩子。我有强力望远镜，待会你离开我办公室时我会展示给你看。用那些望远镜我能看到五个足球场。我不希望一个捕食者和犯罪者，一个被定罪的，被确定曾对我们孩子犯下性行为的人，我不希望那个人从他们的卧室窗口，从他们的客厅窗口向外看，看到一个公园，看到一个游乐场，让这个有犯罪倾向的人去寻找他们的下一个受害者。
The irony, of course, is that Book doesn't need his binocular to see sex offenders anymore. Now he has to deal with them every day.
讽刺的是，当然，布克现在不需要望远镜也能看到性犯罪者了。现在他每天都得和他们打交道。
Isaiah Thompson, he's the former host of The Common Rabble. These days, he's a reporter and columnist at the Philadelphia City Paper .
以赛亚·汤普森，他是《平民暴民》的前主持人。这些天，他是《费城市报》的记者和专栏作家。
[MUSIC - "THERE'S NO HOME FOR YOU HERE" THE WHITE STRIPES].
[音乐 - 白色条纹乐队演唱的《这里没有你的家》]
Well, our program was produced today by Robyn Semien, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Production help from Brian Reed. Special thanks today to Jim McDonough
好了，我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩制作，参与制作的还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·凯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。赛斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。布莱恩·里德提供了制作协助。今天特别感谢吉姆·麦克多诺。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can get our free weekly podcast, or this week read a translation of Mr. Chen's blog about the Yangtze River Bridge and get a link to his Chinese blog, which has tons of pictures. Thanks to Paul Rand by the way, for that translation.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以获取我们的免费周播播客，或者阅读本周关于长江大桥的陈先生博客的翻译，并获取他包含大量图片的中文博客链接。顺便说一句，感谢保罗·兰德的翻译。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. I went to his office this week and asked for a raise and-- I don't know, I think I've been an OK employee. His reaction was kind of weird.
《这美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们节目由WBEZ管理监督，负责人是我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。我这周去他办公室要求加薪——不知道，我想我一直是个合格的员工。他的反应有点奇怪。
I am going to punch you in the face. How dare you? I'm going to punch you right now.
我要打你一拳。你怎么敢？我现在就要打你一拳。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories with This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着《这美国生活》的更多故事回来。
(HOST)  ANNOUNCER. PRI. Public Radio International.
(主持人) 播音员。PRI。国际公共广播电台。